[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
or à tous bienvenue dans ce deuxième
épisode de la saison 3 de six ans par
les sports comme d'habitude nous
parlerons de l'actualité sportive du
département il y aura des analyses des
débats et des duels épiques entre nos
experts pendant près d'une heure pour ce
deuxième numéro la dream team est une
nouvelle fois a réuni dans nos studios
aujourd'hui cinq chroniqueurs les
meilleurs dans leurs disciplines sont en
plateau présentation en musique on
commence à ma droite par l'idée et cause
de cette émission il est notre
spécialiste cyclisme sur route et sur
piste il est champion d'europe master
s'il est également vice-champion du
monde
le très populaire le capitaine yann
dujarrier est avec nous pour cette
émission nous en weekend be stars du
club de vélizy 78 oui je précise
également tout alors y aura notamment du
cyclisme dans cette émission du cyclisme
de haut niveau de compte sur vous pour
vous pour réussir à un dépassement dans
les courbes mais voilà on continue à ma
gauche musique c'est un revenant nous
l'avions quitté au mois de juin dernier
mais il n'a pas hésité à revenir au
galop pour cette deuxième émission de la
saison les cavaliers internationale nous
vient de plaisir en soi même sur ce
plateau le zorro yvelinois ladies and
gentleman raouf cauterets d'autres y est
avec nous pour cette deuxième émission
sans le ciel vous ressortez défilent
bonjour à vous revoir de nous alors vous
nous avez moi et mes amis vous les avez
manqués déjà gouvernement voilà est-ce
que vous allez bien eh ben je vais très
très bien vous avez très bien on
rentrait donc tout se passe très bien
bon on espère vous voir sur les
prochaines émissions j'espère aussi on
passe de l'autre côté à musique c'est la
seule fille présente en plateau
aujourd'hui a fait preuve de courage
pour affronter les titans masculin du
sport et binoy présent aujourd'hui
studio du courage un moment pas pour
affronter les barres de pole dance
toutes les semaines dans son club de
versailles ce sport très physique et qui
mêle acrobaties et danses autour d'une
barre notre ambassadrice de charme la
ravissante helen de la grange est avec
nous pour cette émission
bonjour bonjour hélène alors comment
allez vous aussi tacitement
voilà j'ai envie de revenir comme j'aime
bien j'aime bien alors vous êtes prête
pour cette émission vous avez révisé
avant de dire oui bon j'aime bien
regarder un petit peu on dira
interrogations surprises en tout à
l'heure je serais très surprise on verra
repasse à gauche à musique c'est un
monument du rugby local une star nous
avons dû faire appel aux services de
sécurité pour lui frayer un chemin à
travers un au studio tellement ses fans
étaient nombreux à l'extérieur
entraîneur de plaisir pendant deux
saisons il a dû quitter le département
pour éviter de faire de l'ombre à neymar
mesdames et messieurs le coach jean miss
est avec vous sur ce plateau beaux jours
eagle est ce que c'est une journée à
tous l'homme en est humain physique oman
soit pas de compliquer quand même il est
d'ailleurs comme une allumette à quoi ça
va mais bon voilà
non très bien je suis très heureux
d'être parmi ou encore une fois de plus
j'ai qatari vous en donnez combien pour
quitter le département
j'aurais bien qu'ils m'appellent déjà on
verra plus prologis vraie équipe après
le pit appelle on termine par le
meilleur d'entre nous musique il est à
directeur sportif chez les templiers
d'elancourt c'est le
cerveaux du sport local le einstein des
yvelines ces analyses dignes d'une
opération chirurgicale font à chaque
émission le bonheur des puristes le
professeur flake anderson coder les
clans personnes sur un peu râpé votre
monde est avec nous bonjour frédéric
bonjour tout le monde vous allez bien
slap les arbres se voir comme à chaque
émission excuse après je vous posais la
question est ce que vous avez préparé
quand même l'émission avant de venir
j'ai fait le tour du masters series est
censé nous enseigner toute la science du
sport local pas exactement une chose est
sûre wikipedia hameau de cyclisme pour
commencer l'ex président de la
fédération française de cyclisme david
lappartient que vous voyez à l'écran est
devenu le troisième français président
de l'union cycliste internationale
l'homme de 44 ans a obtenu 37 voix
contre 8 pour son rival le président
sortant le britannique brian thompson
pour rappel david lappartient diriger la
ffc de 2009 à 2017 ainsi que l'union
européenne de cyclisme de 2013 à 2017
il avait son bureau au vélodrome
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
jusqu'en début d'année et son départ de
la fédération française sa nomination
est elle méritée
oui ou non méritée
figé alors vous êtes de à être mitigé
ian pensait alors je suis je suis je
suis assez set fut premièrement je suis
content parce que parce que c'est bien
qu'ils aient un peu usurpée non sur une
fin non mais c'était un petit peu comme
les jeux ou à paris c'est une élection
attendue
ça fait partie de l'échelle
2e les chellois là il était il est au
niveau de l'europe maintenant il prend
la place de du sehy l'europe est la
nation la nation fin par la notion vélo
continent fort dans les représentants
cyclistes c'est un petit peu la suite
logique là où c'est bien c'est que
ça fait un peu de changements les
anglais étaient là depuis depuis très
longtemps au sein du cio
donc c'est bien que ça va peut-être
nouvelles idées maintenant on connaît la
politique de monsieur lappartient
il ya peut-être un petit peu de c'est
peut-être un peu dommage il aurait
peut-être fallu faire faire autre chose
avec vraiment quelque chose de
complètement nouveau
plutôt que de rester dans une dans une
dans une continuité on verra on verra ce
que ça ce que ça pourra donner dans les
dents les prochains prochains mois et
prochaines années maintenant c'est
pareil c'est une les hangars où ils sont
toujours très présents au niveau des
résultats peut-être que ça va aussi
permettre aux cyclistes de france est
d'avoir le résultat des résultats aussi
à l'international pour être un peu plus
de moyens je ne sais pas rires
genlis vous étiez également partagé et
moi j'étais partagé tout simplement
parce que je sais je connais pas sa
valeur donc je vais pas m'engager sur
les choses que je ne connais pas donc il
a commencé sa carrière au niveau
politique dans le cyclisme en 97 il est
devenu président du vélo sport de rhuys
amanda qu'il quittera en 2007 il a été
élu directeur de l'uci en 2005 il aime
le cyclisme depuis longtemps d'accord il
n'en est rien bien sûr la seule chose
qui viennent c'est que les cocoricos m
français à la tête de du cyclisme
international très bien et de plus entre
1 2 et 1 2 plus
brent johnson qui était là juste depuis
quatre ans car mandat c'est trop c'est
trop
il va apprécier je pense raul une
réaction par rapport à cette nomination
voilà il a participé également la mise
en place à la construction du vélodrome
nation de st quentin en yvelines
c'est quelqu'un qui va lancer de grands
projets pour le clan français aux
papiers
forcément j'aurais une réponse - - -
pointu et parce que je suis moins à la
proximité des décisions et du système
que que yann mai
donc c'est quelqu'un déjà qui a du recul
en politique parce qu'il a commencé en
tant que maire il était aussi conseiller
général
en 2013 il est à la tête du vélo
européen donc et puis si je me souviens
bien la réélection du nouveau président
de la fédération française c'était un
peu avant l'été
c'est ça le nouveau président disait
qu'on lui avait refilé un bébé qui était
pas en si mauvaise et axa donc bon pour
quelqu'un comme moi qui suis ça d'assez
loin par rapport à hier sur le papier je
peux que dire que c'est que c'est mérité
faudrait qu anderson on lui reprochait
notamment de ne pas être proche du
cyclisme amateur des des cyclistes qui
font du vélo le dimanche pour pour
caricaturer
est ce que ça peut être positif ou
négatif pour lui ça dans sa nouvelle
prise de fonction c'est compliqué parce
que là il est là il est à la tête d'une
structure gigantesque c'est quand même
l'ordre monde feint de l'eau lors du
vélo c'est quand même la plus grosse
instances internationales cycliste c'est
l'équivalent la fifa donc forcément
force forcément plus on monte dans les
étages plus on s'éloigne de la base
c'est vrai qu'on a peut-être peut-être
parfois tendance à oublier que la
majorité des pratiquants bas et on les
voit pas souvent on n'en parle pas à la
télé et il faut et c'est quand même eux
qui font qu'ils font vivre le sport au
quotidien donc il faut pas les oublier
et c'est vrai que quand on est rentré
dans des considérations politiques et
d'organisations compliqué on a vite fait
de se concentrer sur les luttes le haut
niveau et d'oublier un peu à tous ces
gens qui au quotidien font vivre le vélo
et après je pense que c'est dans le
timing c'est un peu c'est un peu parfait
parce que ça ça arrive avec la
nomination de marie losio on a levé le
drone juste à côté donc on peut penser
que sa nomination va permettre aussi de
mieux préparer de faire une meilleure
transition vers les vers dans les geôles
des jeux olympiques pour le pour le
cyclisme donc je pense que c'est assez
cohérent de ce point de vue là hélène
est ce qu'on pensait que ça va
changer beaucoup de choses au niveau du
cyclisme français
cette nomination le fait qu'ils soient
français comme disait yann c'était un
anglais précédemment alors moi ce que je
reproche peut-être au personnage c'est
c'est que c'est un cycliste en fait
c'est un politicien qui s'intéresse aux
cyclistes et qui a aimé cyclisme et ça
n'a pas été un dirais pas un grand nom
du cyclisme mais ça qu il a il a
certainement cru quand il était plus
jeune mais voilà c'est pas un c'est pas
quelqu'un qui a été nourri et à vacciner
par avait avec un rayon comme on a pu
comme moi je peux l'être où beaucoup de
pratiquants peuvent l'être et peut-être
que voilà c'est un vrai politicien comme
tu disais il est maire il est maire de
sa commune il est
il avait donc roy compte en même temps
il présente le président aussi de la
communauté de communes
la wii alors bien sûr qu'il fait des
choses pour le cyclisme de même au sein
de sa commune
même si le projet de son vélodrome est
apparemment un peu risque risque de
capoter
maryse de capoter sur la bretagne mais
voilà ces mots voilà j'ai moi je trouve
ça dommage que ce soit des gens qu'ils
soient politiciens plutôt que
pratiquants qui soit à la tête de ces
deux saisons de ses 1 200 français et il
a sûrement des sonneries je ne pense pas
qu est un français ça influe sur les 19
ans et ce serait pas normal déjà ça
c'est parce qu'il prenne la place
suprême du cyclisme mondial en tant que
président de l'uci qui va favoriser plus
les français se serait pas normal
donc ça va rien changer aux français est
relou va trouver dans le rugby avec
bernard lapasset
voilà ça on n'est pas plus avantagés
encore moi même
le protégé de d'aider les petites
nations à se développer plutôt que les
grosses nations puisque la france fait
partie des grosses nations du cyclisme à
avoir des moyens supplémentaires c'est
pas c'est alors c'est pas leur rôle sur
ce thème
on va passer maintenant au programme de
l'émission aujourd'hui nous allons
parler de rugby avec la très belle
victoire du ska rugby contre lee mais
pour leur premier match de la saison en
honneur
nous parlerons également du décès de
ligne montrent un philippe médard il a
remporté en 1992 la première médaille
dur au mal français mais avant de
développer ces thèmes coup de projecteur
sur un record
[Musique]
jeannette augusto 82 ans vient d'établir
une performance exceptionnelle dans la
catégorie d'âge 80 ans et plus elle a
réalisé 28 226 km en 1h sur la piste du
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines
une première mondiale la sportive qui
portait le maillot de leusse et vélizy
78 s'est même offert le luxe de réaliser
112 tours de piste quatre de plus que
les prévisions de ses coachs on écoute
sa première réaction micro de tv 78 et
pas ça s'est très bien passé et je ne
pensais vraiment pas faire une telle
performance
alors là franchement non je voulais pas
descendre en dessous les vingt-sept et
bien là je crois que je suis gâté qui
est une performance qui a épaté son
entraîneur jean michel richefort qu'on a
souvent reçu sur ce plateau pour six ans
par les sports il a entraîné pendant
plusieurs mois avec des séances de 40
kilomètres tous les deux jours en écoute
il ya toujours une part d'incertitude
on n'est jamais sûr d'aller jusqu'au
bout et jeannette elle ne s'est jamais
désuni elle a toujours rouler
régulièrement
et puis elle n'a jamais fléchi surtout
jusqu'à la fin elle a été régulière et
ça c'est une une très très grande leçon
même tout pour tous les grands cyclistes
une réaction autour de ce record pour ce
record de cette table yann est en fait
en voyant les images je me dis que c'est
quand même dommage d'aller d'aller
titiller afin d'établir sur ce genre de
performance et de ne pas ceux de pas
mettre tous les moyens
en ordre en place pour obtenir la
meilleure performance encore une fois le
matériel on est sur un vélo un vélo de
baptême et
le même type de vélo qui que l'on peut
avoir quand on vient faire son baptême
au vélodrome est donc pas une position
aérodynamique on n'a pas les rookie
alors à ce niveau-là de performance les
routes servir à rien d'ailleurs mais bon
plein ça ne servirait à rien à moins de
30 kilomètres a de toute façon mais
voilà je trouve qu'une position et euros
ça me permettrait de gagner quelques
quelques kilomètres et donc je me dis
c'est dommage parce que eh bien
quelqu'un qui s'investit un petit peu
plus pourrait battre cette performance
assez rapidement maintenant faut vouloir
faire du vélo à 82 ans
et c'est vrai que c'est ce qu'elle a
fait ça reste ça reste quand même très
très simple audika par les routes
deux petites au bout derrière 400 deux
ans avec cette personne qui a été
mitigée qui tient vraiment qui est pas
du tout ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que
tout ce qu'il faut savoir c'est quand
même elle entraîne dujarrier ici
présents qui part au fait du monde
masters c'est sur l'entraîneur on va
effectivement killian acquiesce mal
comment de l'esprit
régulièrement alors ce record nous fait
forcément penser à celui de robert
marchand du coup didier raoult il ya
quelques instants qui avait réalisé en
janvier dernier sur cette même piste du
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
22,5 147 mètres en une heure devant plus
de 2000 spectateurs et les médias du
monde entier la question sur ce thème le
record de jeunesse est il de la même
ampleur que celui de robert marchand oui
ou non voter allez-y prenez vos petites
raquettes
non oui on va faire un petit duel entre
raul et fenech
j'ai pas non plus une batterie
d'arguments à exposer mais d'abord je
trouve que jahjaga y avait il ya vingt
ans des cards pour la pousser pour cette
simple et bonne raison que c'est on
attend les bras sur un même on envoie
des des octogénaires pratique est encore
un sport est assez bien conservés mais
sans cinq ans pour moi enfin au dessus
de 100 ans et quand même c'est
titanesque avec moi je dis que c'était à
peu près la même ampleur du simple fait
que ce n'avait pas été fait avant
du coup c'est et l'établissement d'un
nouveau record donc de ce point de vue
là c'était robert marchand également
établi un record
donc je vais rester le point commun
entre les deux après effectivement il ya
quand même 20 ans d'écart c'est parce
qu'une génération entre les entre les
deux participants après ce qui est
vraiment intéressant sur sur cet
événement là bas c'est justement comment
disais juste avant d'être coupé de la
base ben là c'est un type d'événement
qui peut concerner beaucoup de monde et
je pense que c'est peut-être plus
intéressant comme nouvelle comme
événement que la nomination d'un penser
à la tête à la tête de l'us et je pense
hélène qui a raison qui a tort joe raul
a réussi à vous faire changer d'avis les
des arguments sont les arguments sont
sont bons il a raison dans ce qu'il dit
on n'est pas sur les mêmes tranches
d'âge et c'est maintenant
on est
la com com utilisé sur un nouveau record
là en plus on a une femme un an qu'on
avait un homme auparavant
on est sur des performances un peu
différente je pense que ça mérite d'être
souligné il ya l'entraînement derrière
c'est pour moi on est sûr quand même sur
des pionniers même si a déjà vu un
premier record jeu comme témoigne hélène
non je rejoins de tora où le joueur est
complètement raul parce que c'est la
raison pour laquelle vous avez j'avais
mis rouge simplement voilà ils n'ont pas
du tout ménage
maintenant quand on voit la forme de
jeannette on peut on peut se dire
qu'elle va en refaire dans les halles a
dit qu'elle allait arrêter ça serait son
dernier record ses saucissons d'un
territoire n'est rien mais bon elle a
pas vraiment jean michel richefort qui
je crée des biens est quelqu'un de très
persuasif la différence aussi avec
robert marchand ian c'est le guidon
aussi le guide on n'était pas tout à
fait le même au niveau du vélo il
n'avait pas la même posture alors déjà
une grande aire robert marie sans la
bassiste robert avec un très petit donc
à mettre 50 cc beaucoup de compliqué
d'avoir d'avoir des vélos qui permettent
de d'avoir d'avoir un guide ont allongé
et en plus robert l'a fait avec un avec
un vélo de route alors que
alors que jeannette l'a fait avec un
vide est un vrai qu'un vrai vélo piste
robert avait avait des freins et voyez
on voit là c'est pas des dons enfin du
coup la position de robert et qui est
une position qui est plus adapté à pour
aller rouler sur la sur la route voilà
tout simplement
donc du coup et c'est sa position
confortable voyez il est très droit sur
sur son vélo c'est une position
confortable pour pouvoir faire des
kilomètres quand il quand il va rouler
autour de autour de chez lui ou alors
qui va faire les étapes de montagne
comme il aime le faire et robert
marchand n'est pas monté dans les
virages également à cette occasion mais
parce que il a où il roulait à une
vitesse trop peu trop faible pour
pouvoir rouler pour pouvoir tenir sur
sur la piste audio dont une cinquantaine
évident il faut rouler au delà de 26 km
1 et jamais été à 28 km voilà donc
jamais pouvait se le permettre alors que
robert ne pouvait pas le faire il a
également remis ce une dimension peut
être symbolique aussi dans leur corps de
jane est elle a couru notamment pour
avec le maillot de vélizy 78 pour
remercier le club 47 ans après avoir
réalisé pour le club le record de france
sur piste du 500 m départ arrêté est ce
qu a une dimension symbolique aussi qui
est qui ajoute forcément la performance
de gêne et augusto contrairement à
robert marchand qui arrivait sur sur la
piste du vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines one dispose
pas forcément pour faire pour établir
son record à lui pas forcément pour
établir un record pour un club
voilà je pense que c'est plus un petit
clin d'oeil connaît en remerciement au
club dans lequel elle a pratiqué ce ce
genre de choses mais en moi honnêtement
je passe quand on aura plus de personnes
capables de faire autant aussi bien et
même mieux
à 82 ans qu'on va me trouver à 150 c'est
pour ça que je me peu mitigé sahin
s'installe c'est magnifique du monde et
il faut savoir que dans la catégorie
plus de 75 ans il y à des jeunes
papilles de 80 ans qui viennent
concourir tous les ans pour les
championnats du monde et y avait des
performances qui sont très honorables et
avec d un comportement de cadets le même
état d'esprit que ce que pouvait dégager
jeannette quand quand elle dit quand
elle discute c'est vrai que ce sont des
cc lacq où on voit que le cyclisme est
un sport santé et qui peut être
pratiquée à tous les âges c'est que même
la compétition n'est pas fermée quand on
a plus de 75 ans et moi j'adore voir les
compétitions de vitesse ou de course à
points de plus de 75 ans parce que bah
ils s'amusent sur le vélo et c'est
vraiment très sympa donc on peut faire
du vélo jusqu'à 105 ans ben regarde déjà
une robert nous l'a déjà trouvé mais le
vélo est directement tenir jusqu'à cet
âge là c'est un fait partie d'eads et
des sports qui conserve le plus pas
microtraumatismes c'est vrai que c'est
il faut pas chuter bien sûr parce que
mon compte des 25 ans ou qu'on en ait 75
je pense que les conséquences sont les
dauphins pas les conséquences on est là
mais les risques sont les mêmes
maintenant voilà c'est vrai que si si on
arrive à éliminer ces sept ce risque de
chute et bien
on arrive à prendre beaucoup de plaisir
faut savoir que à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines tous les
vendredis midi il y a un créneau réservé
aux plus de 60 ans et donc qui est
complet tous les vendredis midis et
c'est vrai qu'il ya une ambiance qui est
cassé sympa il donc si vous avez plus de
60 ans soit et partez pas à venir faire
quelques tours de roue avec eux raul
pourquoi jeannette le record de
jeannette a moins attiré les foules que
celui de robert marchand il y avait qu
elle parce que le monde entier s'est
déplacé pour son père marchand dans tous
les sports dans tous les domaines
la barre des 100 ans elle est toujours
plus impressionnant je trouve qu'il ya
passé la barre des 100 temps même quand
c'est pas dans le sport selon dans la
vie de tous les jours c'est quelque
chose qui percute qui percute beaucoup
plus je pense pas qu'ils aient de
raisons femme ou homme si ça avait été
l'inversé je pense c'est cette image de
l'âge au dessus de son temps et même moi
je fais partie de ces gens qui le seront
beaucoup plus impressionné grecques
alpha ce dernier sûr et il faudrait
qu'elle fasse d'autres records pour
rentrer dans la légende
yann sur vous l es gens dans la légende
je pense que ses rapporteurs d'un sport
je pense que ce sont des acteurs élite
qui peuvent rentrer dans les jambes d'un
sport maintenant oui si elle faisait
d'autres records comme plus tard elle
pourrait elle pourrait se faire
connaître
d'une part et pas simplement du monde du
cyclisme et ou du monde des pistards
mais peut-être peut-être voilà ouvrir
ouvrir un petit peu plus son son spectre
à quoi on referme ce thème jeannette
augusto je le rappelle a annoncé la fin
de sa carrière après cette performance
en tout cas sur le papier jan
on lui tire une nouvelle fois un grand
coup de chapeau on continue cette page
résultats par du rugby je vous vois déjà
sourire j'en lis en championnat ile de
france honneur le sky rugby n'a pas
manqué son retour après trois ans
d'absence le dimanche 1er octobre les
saint quentinois sont venus à bout de
menthe l'imea sur leur terrain le score
23 à 22
résultat acquis dans les dernières
secondes dans une ambiance électrique
avec un essai inscrit au bout du temps
réglementaire on écoute les réactions à
la fin du match ça fait du bien de
revenir avec une victoire et c'est vrai
que moi à l'époque j'étais j'étais pas
au sky
le capitaine y était et son mode fin de
match c'est à dire que vous avez fait
deux saisons sans aucune victoire en
honneur et de recommencer une halle en
division honneur par une victoire ça
fait du bien à tout le monde au moral
aux très bons résultats du sky rugby
pour ce premier match de la saison en
honneur après trois ans à d'absents je
le disais dans cette division une
performance qui contraste avec les
résultats des autres promus yvelinois en
fédérale 2 plaisir a perdu une nouvelle
fois contre beauvais sur le score de 53
29 ce 1er octobre le club à zéro point
en trois matches même désillusion pour
le club de montigny le bretonneux qui
s'est incliné pour son premier match en
promotion d'honneur 27 à 3 contre
marcoussis le thème la question sur ce
thème
est-ce que c'est plus facile de se
maintenir dans les petites divisions
quand on est promu est-ce que c'est plus
simple parce que c'est plus facile
oui non peut-être partagé en faire un
petit duel entre jean et fenech
l'écart des cigales tapé jean alesi tu
as perdu
j'ai déjà perdu allez-y oui bien sûr
tout à fait quand on va dans l'est dans
les divisions régionales alors plus on
descend ça c'est pas compliqué plus on
descend plus c'est facile de se
maintenir au niveau au niveau supérieur
dès qu'on commence à approcher d'honneur
de région de rejoindre la fédérale 3 on
se figure bien c'est à dire que les
grandes équipes de donneurs celles qui
font des phases finales jeunes plein de
phases finales finissent en haut du
tableau se comporte très bien après en
fédérale 3 on al'exemple la saison
dernière de sucy en brie qui a fait demi
finales du championnat de france honneur
et qui a fait qui a fait les phases
finales de fédérale 3 la saison dernière
y'a pas de soucis par contre à partir de
la fédérale 3 plus vous montez puis la
marche
elle est importante entre les divisions
on le voit très bien à travers plaisir
cette saison qui a dominé la fédérale 3
sa poule la saison dernière et qu'il a
comme je voulais dit d'ailleurs comme je
voulais prédit je suis remarquer le
faire remarquer les bailleurs et les
agresseurs et les téléspectateurs
pourront voir sans réplique il ferait un
mauvais rêve ils prennent l'eau donc
c'est la marche c'est un peu plus
important et elle est d'autant plus de
fédérale 2 et fédérale eut et je vous
dis alors ne parlons pas après on le
voit très bien plus on monte dans ses
divisions à partir de la fédérale 3 à la
fédérale 2 plus vous montez plus le
fossé grands fans avec un peu comme jean
louis froment dans la pyramide plus
forcément on affronte des plus grosses
équipes
après je pense que c'est pas c'est
peut-être plus c'est peut-être parce que
les comment dire les canards je n'ai pas
raison il avait dit qu'il allait gagner
avant d'évincer c'est peut-être plus
comment est structuré la différence de
niveau est par exemple au football
américain n'y a pas forcément d'énormes
différences entre entre la deuxième et
la première division ce qui fait qu'un
promu du football américain en division
supérieure aura pas forcément plus de
difficultés au plus de facilité à ce
point de tenir parce que
au sein de la division de première
division et la cam a déjà un gros écart
ce qui fait que l'écart entre les deux
divisions une et deux pas le bas de la
le bas de la 1re division et le haut de
la deuxième division sont assez proches
ce qui fait que finalement il n'y a pas
plus de différence qu'on soit entre 3e
et 2e que entre deuxième et première
c'est plus la question comment est
structuré la division elle même le
niveau de la division elle même qui va
faire est-ce que c'est plus ou moins
difficile donc je pense que ça doit
dépendre aussi en fonction des sports et
en fonction des en fonction des bad et
du nombre de participants qu hier parce
que franchement pas rentrer à une
division il ya plus de poule quand
deuxième donc c'est peut-être plus
facile de la structure et de la
structure donc rester en troisième
division quand on manque de régionales
quand on monte devrait de 3e division en
première division
parce qu'il ya moins de place et
forcément les pages sont plus chers je
suis pas tellement sûr que ce soit une
question de
est-ce que c'est plus facilement facile
ça va dépendre un peu au cas par cas je
pense
raul vous donner raison à jean louis
simon professeur du rugby depuis que
jean et puis à plaisir est-ce que je
pense que la seule chance que quand on
quand une promotion a lieu que seul et
les choses soient plus faciles c'est
quand ça cet événement la donne
justement la possibilité à un accès à
des rats une évolution peut être un
entraîneur meilleures armées du meilleur
équipement un plus gros investissement
parce que la catégorie est supérieur si
c'est pas le cas forcément plus plus on
monte plus l'étau se resserre et puis
les choses sont difficiles pour se
maintenir
hélène quand on voit mon team bretonneux
finalement c'est le contre exemple ils
sont dans une vision plus basque euskal
rugby et finalement ils perdent voilà
avec 20 points pris en première période
contre contre marcoussis est-ce que
c'est finalement contre exemple oui là
c'est un peu la défaite cuisante
ça peut être un as qu un incident par
coup on peut considérer ça mais hélas
c'est un peu de contre exemple c'est
vrai moi j'ai un jour joignez plutôt les
arguments de voilà de frédéric peut-être
qu'il ya une histoire de structures
aussi mais je réduis genre quand même
quand on regarde leur et quand on
regarde le résultat de monty bretonneux
on peut se dire que ça peut contredire
votre argument le résultat d'un duel
c'est le résultat du match c'est la fin
de la saison serrée fait du mal qu'on
peut leur caisse et du coup en fédérale
2 justement pour en revenir à plaisir en
fédérale 2 ou 10 et il ya une part
également peut-être physique aussi qui
rentre en compte au niveau des joueurs
forcément le niveau augmente il ya plus
de physique contrairement à aux
catégories plus basse la première
première série la promotion d'honneur
bien sûr c'est tout à fait logique plus
de physique plus de ça va plus vite
les impacts sont plus en plus elles sont
plus intenses et tout va toujours plus
vite plus vous montez plus on va vite et
plus et plus c'est dur physiquement et
plus ça fait mal donc c'est pour ça que
si vous dévouement t il faut
obligatoirement faire évoluer votre
groupe et
charlie j'ai quoi changer certains
joueurs aient apporté des joueurs
d'expérience pour pouvoir espérer se
maintenir
parce que là vous parlez de plaisir tout
à fait mais plaisir plaisir c'est le
troisième match de troisième fois qu'ils
prennent à 52 points moi je voulais dire
c'est certain certains vont me dire
ouais mais tu sais pas ce que c'est
l'ancien entraîneur l'ange suis pas
spécialement compte à un cépage est pas
content du tout parce que je suis
sportif avant tout mais c'est la réalité
des choses je vous le dis il faut être
faut être lucide dans la vie est encore
souvent voilé score final mais bon il
faut savoir quand même que à la mi temps
le match plié à chaque fois encore
dimanche qu on trouve existe trois
plaisir à une différence de moins 90
cents sur les trois premiers pays j'ai
encore parce qu'ils font des secondes
périodes où les entraîneurs adverses
sortent leurs cadres et font entrer
leurs remplaçants puisque les trois
premiers matches le premier match et les
40 à 3 à la mi-temps le deuxième match à
un quart d'heure la fille avait 57 à 7
et puis là ça finit à 53 29 on peut se
dire le résultat final on dit haye a que
24 points c'est pas énorme sais pas mais
si c'est énorme ça c'est la manière 46 à
3 à la mi temps 46 à 3,46 à 3
l'entraîneur de beauvais il a fait
sortir tout tout tout tout tout ses
cadres pour les protéger parce que la
saison est à 9 heures faites vite voilà
voilà et après il met un petit comptable
est donc en seconde période après mais
ils gagnent entre guillemets la seconde
période mais c'est pas significatif
j'espère qu'ils se reposent pas là
dessus contrairement à ce que des fois
ce que je lis sur les réseaux sociaux et
la qui se repose là-dessus donc c'est un
peu dommage je vois ces mannequins de
lucidité qu'avant le message est passé
auprès des dirigeants et des joueurs
et quelle est la solution yann pour pour
se maintenir justement c'est le
recrutement la préparation il faut
préparer mentalement les joueurs aussi à
à vivre une saison compliquée forcèment
forcément mon team bretons les gagner
tous ses matchs la saison dernière il
avait tout de suite premier match
première défaite le squer rugby paris
dont gagné tous leurs matches
heureusement ça se passe bien sûr ce
premier match miserait plus également
perdre
est-ce qu'il faut les préparer
mentalement si lui il faut pas parler
les gens mentalement parce qu'une saison
saison c'est non
contrairement à contrairement à des
sports individuels comme je pratique où
on a des objectifs précis à certains
moments de la saison là il faut avoir
une forme constante pendant toute
l'année est donc belle a eu toutes ces
tous ces clubs qui viennent qui sont
montés de division de la nation dernière
censure une phase d'apprentissage et
donc qui va peut-être durer trois quatre
cinq matches qui durera peut-être la
moitié de la saison
qui qu'il durera peut-être toute la
saison et ils n'arriveront pas à se
mettre au niveau et ils redescendront
malheureusement malheureusement en fin
de saison
maintenant il va on gagne c'est il faut
pas croire fauvin on ne gagne pas ou on
ne perd pas on gagne oui mais quand on
perd on apprend et donc c'est dans la
défaite que dans la défaite il faut
avoir l'intelligence de servir des
bonnes choses etc il est utilisé dans
l'est dans les prochaines dans les
prochaines compétitions pour pour
pouvoir rivaliser avec avec le niveau
dans lequel on nous aurons vient
d'arriver faut savoir si l'adversaire à
montigny-le-bretonneux était une équipe
du haut de tableau de la promotion
d'honneur l'équipe adverse équipe voilà
donc c'est une des meilleures équipes
forcément vous attaquer directement par
un gros morceau de la division
supérieure donc
voilà c'est le résultat de neige
dernière question genre on va faire un
pronostic avec vous vous êtes très fort
en pronostics le ska rugby va se
maintenir à faire ma saison
lorsqu'un rugby pour jeu pour les avoir
joués en amical
je pense qu'ils se maintiendront
d'accord plaisir plaisir
ce sera très très très très difficile
pour moi une semaine en bas il faut
mentir retenu non je vous interpelle
surtout parce qu'on verrait à ce que je
dis ce sera très très difficile aidée
pour moi en toute lucidité je pense
qu'ils arriveront et mantilles me
retenais montillot voto l'un sur un
match c'est compliqué je ne connais pas
du tout je peux parler des équipes que
je connais skies et vu mon team
bretonneux je ne les connais pas mais
encore une fois il faut c'est un match
est donc le premier match contre une
grosse équipe
attendons de voir le résultat tu peux
plus on continuera à les suivre cette
saison dans ceux ci ont parlé sport on
continue donc ceux ci ont parlé de sport
pour notre coup de projecteur triste
nouvelle pour le sport évinois ligne
montrent un philippe médard médaille
olympique à barcelone en 1992 avec les
fameux bronze et c'était 1 ce samedi à
58 ans des suites d'une longue maladie
depuis le début des années 2000 le
gardien aider le club de la smb il avait
également exercé des fonctions dans
l'administration communale à la
direction des services techniques à la
direction des sports de
montigny-le-bretonneux
on écoute la réaction de patrick chabot
membres du bureau directeur de mon team
bretonne il a entraîné les gardiens de
but du club donc il ya beaucoup de
jeunes filles actuellement qui joue en
nationale 2 il ya là une notamment qui
lui doit beaucoup
et puis en même temps il a encadré les
s'est occupée des seniors garçons
pendant plusieurs années au niveau de
l'entraînement donc elle était vraiment
très investi au niveau du cloud pour
nous c'est difficile de voir quelqu'un
disparaître certes d'une longue maladie
mais ça fait mal quoi jean que pensez
vous de son attachement à pour
montigny-le-bretonneux
il arrivait du coup il ya une quinzaine
d'années au club qu'est ce que vous en
pensez vous en tant que coach
est ce que c'est important pour un club
d'avoir une star comme lui avait bien
sûr bien sûr que c'est important
c'est d'autant plus important qu'en plus
c'est surtout le plus apte pour thèse
c'est que une star puis sur revenir à ne
pas oublier d'où il vient et ça c'est
bien parce que voilà c'était sont des
joueurs qui veut qu'ils ont ils sont
partis évolué au niveau qui ont eu des
sélections en équipe de france céder des
titres et qui reviennent aider leur club
ce n'est pas son club d'origine il est
arrivé en fait
il ya une quinzaine d'années ici à
montigny-le-bretonneux est le premier
club resté dans sa vie et il est allé
les aider c'est bon c'est pas son club
mais le le principe le principe était un
peu le même cas le raisonnement
voilà il redonne à la discipline à son
club d'origine
mais à la discipline il redonne 0 2 que
la discipline ne lui a donné lui offert
yann c est admiratif également du fait
qu'il vienne dans un club amateur qui
les aide qui forment les gardiens de
cette équipe d'ailleurs des gardiennes
qui sont en nationale 2 mce négatif non
mais c'est vrai que beaucoup de sportifs
de haut niveau devraient prendre exemple
sur ce genre de personnage parce que
beaucoup alors ils ont aussi leurs
raisons mais c'est vrai que beaucoup
quand ils arrêtent leur carrière peuvent
être un peu aussi fatigué dégoûté par
par leur sport oubli justement comment
est-ce qu'ils sont arrivés à ce haut
niveau et parfois ben ce serait bien
qu'ils passent que leur expérience peut
servir à beaucoup et ce serait voilà
beaucoup de sportifs devraient peut-être
parfois même après une période de pause
revenir et s'occuper de s'occuper de la
base pourrait passer un petit peu de
temps comme des gens l'ont fait pour eux
à certains moments ça c'est quelque
chose qui devrait être important qui
doit être inculqué dans beaucoup de faim
dans le c'est pas trés c'est pas très
français de le fermer
mais voilà que ça ça devrait être
éducatif et il faudrait que ce soit fait
beaucoup plus souvent vous êtes d'accord
oui oui je suis d'accord c'est vrai que
souvent on a les montées d un des
meilleurs voilà qui finalement reste
dans ces sphères là et ont toujours une
visée vers le haut de leur performance
mais en effet d'autres ont été là pour
eux avant et c'est bien d'eux
oui de retourner s'occuper d'eux voilà
d'où vient des mâts désespoir qui
viennent dans sa discipline et même un
peu dans l'organisation aussi je vais
jetter corps est alors philippe médard
n'est pas un personnage très connu du
grand public
il a surtout remporté la première
médaille du handball français le bronze
aux jo de barcelone en 92 selon patricia
billy a eu un avant et un après pour le
handball tricolore après cette victoire
en 1992 et les performances de philippe
médard on écoute il a été à l'origine
une formidable épopée au niveau de
l'équipe de france et c'est vrai que
c'était un gardien de but c'était la
figure et lorsqu'on j'étais spectateur à
l'époque
enfin téléspectateurs de voir la
qualification et puis là et permettre
d'avoir en plus la première médaille de
aux jeux olympiques pour une équipe de
france de handball et après c'est tout a
enchaîné avec toute cette même bande de
copains vous le connaissiez ou pas du
tout autour de la table jean miss vous
le connaissiez je vous laisse étonnant
mais parce que j'ai arm11 et pas à pas
un barrage initiée par jour j'ai des
potes sera ok qui était au niveau d'un
dans le handball donc je le connaissais
pas personnellement vous faut pas
oublier que dans ces années là donc leur
donne en france n'était pas très connu
mais il y avait surtout une personne qui
était emblématique en équipe de france
était jackson richardson et donc c'est
le seul nom qui reste de c2c de ces
épopées là puisqu'il était aussi vite et
aussi à tenter de 96 et déjà l'an 92 à
barcelone
et c'est vrai que il a une telle aura
médiatique jackson que c'était difficile
pour les autres d'exister dans une
discipline qui était méconnu du grand
public français la personne qu'elle
place à philippe bédard pour leur bal
français le sport français
bon pour le sport français il restera
comme un des fondateurs bas de toute la
montée en puissance du handball après je
pense que pour beaucoup
donc ma génération ne connais pas plus
que ça passe quand 92 moi j'avais 7 ans
seront que forcément meura pdg au de 92
sap est loin elle a petit jeune mais
c'est vrai qu'après je pense que pour
mon tunis est une grosse perte
ne serait ce que pour l'aspect humain
parce que derrière tout le savoir faire
et tout l'aspect enseignement etc
il ya une personne qui était investie
dans la vie du club et qui disparaît
comme ça même si c'est pas aussi brutale
on n'est jamais prêt à perdre quelqu'un
quelle que soit la raison et je pense
que oui je pense que c'est une grande
perte pour tout le monde et c'est bien
le but rendre hommage et d'en parler ah
oui il était très humble
d'après ce qu'ont ce qu'on disait à
montigny-le-bretonneux est ce qui nous
manquait pas peut-être un peu
d'excentricité un peu plus d'aura
médiatique pour qu'on se souvienne de
lui complètement aujourd'hui mais ça
comme jackson richardson aurait changé
conventionnelle je veux vraiment le sens
vu la nature du personnage ça pouvait
pas coller avec justement le média et sa
starification c'est très peu commun son
itinéraire dans le sport les
l'itinéraire classique d'un ancien
sportif de haut niveau c'est d'aller
vendre son expertise ensuite dans les
clubs les plus riches soit en france
soit à l'étranger
moi j'aime fin très rarement entendu
parler de d'un sportif de haut niveau
qui qui fait un retour à ses origines
comme ça et qui est qui et qui revient
sur justement sur des sur des sportifs
de loisirs et c'est donc toute façon en
été dans on est et on était sur un
personnage qui était complètement en
dehors de ceux de ce schéma là donc le
média je pense que ça n'avait rien à
voir avec eux c'est aussi un petit peu
assez ça correspond au poste de gardien
de but dans le land c'est quand même un
an quand on voit thierry omeyer
aujourd'hui c'est pareil c'est un
personnage qui est en retrait qui
s'impose comme d'ailleurs qui sait
romeyer et bruno martini qui ont été
formés alors voilà il est le continent a
ordonné les conseils encore sur ces
dernières années et c'est marrant parce
que ça que aujourd'hui tirer et ouais
mais thierry omeyer c'est pour moi c'est
le gardien emblématique des dernières
années parce que un peu parlé des
proches justement tu dis pas ça par sa
part sa longévité
bon qui va enfin peut-être arrêter sa
carrière mais c'est pareil
martini nous vous parlais juste avant
c'est fait partie mais c'est vraiment un
poste peut être ingrat mais ses impôts
ce qui est très très glorifiant shirel
est presque plus déterminant que dans
une équipe de foot parce que ça bien sûr
ils sont beaucoup plus en action je
pense que j'ai beaucoup d'admiration
pour les garçons avec fall dans ce sport
la viande il faut s'y mettre la veille
et gagne de rugby on peut dire gens qui
l'a uni si vraiment les futures
victoires françaises voilà la france on
peut dire aujourd'hui est la meilleure
nation au niveau du handball au monde
est ce qu'on peut dire qu'ils qu'il a
initié un mouvement voilà il a été avec
les bronzés il a initié les barjots il a
plus ou moins conseillé tous les joueurs
de l'équipe de france qui ont suivi avec
jackson richardson aussi qui a continué
est ce qu'on peut dire qu'il a initié un
mouvement pareil au niveau des chiffres
le handball avant qu'il arrive c'était
183 me licencier en 90 et aujourd'hui
c'est plus de 500 milles est-ce qu'il a
initié un mouvement
forcément on fait même pas lui
personnellement à l'équipe
l'équipe l'équipe c'est le départ de
cette grande épopée du handball français
est forcément commis les gardiens comme
raul est bien de le dire c'est un des
postes clés du handball est forcément en
plus il a continué à transmettre son
savoir auprès des sportifs qui ont
perpétré la tradition du handball
français
donc on ne peut bien sûr que reconnaître
qui fait partie de ce groupe qui a amené
qui a amené qui a amené le handball
français est tel qu'il est aujourd'hui
quoi je me souviens après après des jeux
olympiques de rio
où les barjots n'ont apporté que la
médaille d'argent la déception de
beaucoup de gens faut pas oublier voilà
les barjots c'est maintenant une feinte
lélex des réserves et les voilà le type
de france de hand c'est quand même
quelque chose qui perdure et qui
j'espère que les volleyeurs feront
feront de même mais messai que cette
équipe de hand lé lé lé elle est quand
même énorme et cc c'est super ce qu'ils
ont réussi à faire est en effet ces
équipes parce que c'est pas un homme
cette équipe c'est cette équipe-là dont
il va dont il a fait partie qui a acquis
et qui est à l'initiative de derrida
qu'on peut avoir aujourd'hui
voilà pour les téléspectateurs
l'enterrement se déroulera le 6 octobre
à mon team pro de montigny-le-bretonneux
pardon on passe maintenant notre focus
du jour on va parler de golf
[Musique]
on prend maintenant la direction dans
cette émission du golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines le parcours de
l'albatros a accueilli du 28 au 30
septembre la deuxième édition du paris
ce legend championship un tournoi
professionnel réservé au jour depuis de
50 ans est organisé en partenariat avec
la fédération française de golf cette
année une cinquantaine de joueurs pros
sont venus participer à la compétition
en écoute l'un des organisateurs c'est
une épreuve de deluz open senior tour
c'est la douzième épreuve je crois de du
calendrier de ce circuit professionnel
c'est l'open de france seniors et puis
après on a des pointures mondiales comme
john delli comme paul broadhurst comme
costantino rocca voilà des joueurs qui
nous ont fait vibrer il ya quelques
années qui joue encore très très bien du
côté du public il n'y a pas eu
d'effervescence pourtant les joueurs se
sont démenés sur l'albatros de saint
quentin en yvelines le fantasque john
delli à relizane du superbe coup et
l'anglais paul brottes hearst a remporté
la compétition
vingt-deux ans après avoir remporté
l'open de france à saint quentin en
yvelines avec un total de moins 12 pour
admirer ces performances ils n'étaient
que quatre mille cinq cents spectateurs
mais tous ont trouvé la compétition
intéressante
c'est un très joli tournoi avec des gens
qu'on a connus dali fin des grandes et
grands joueurs et masi colvert j'ai bien
aimé
jusqu'à maintenant j'ai bien aimé ça
intéresse un public notamment beaucoup
de gens qui ont passé la soixantaine
joue encore au golf donc on est toujours
un peu concernés comme des gens de notre
âge qui joue encore et qui joue aussi
bien la question sur ce thème le pari
sladen championship un tournoi inutiles
ou un tournoi avec un vrai enjeu inutile
rouge vrais enjeux vers vous mettait
il faut trancher en jeu inutile on fait
un petit débat un petit duel entre vous
et raul et hélène ses 1 200 élèves
c'est un petit métier mais l'ancien
allez-y je pense pas que ce soit un réel
enjeu non plus c'est pas vraiment
inutile c'est quand même un tournoi
c'est voilà ça qu'on a une petite place
mais c'est pas non pus sera bientôt moi
qui ait conservé que les plus de 50 ans
explique donc pour vous il ya quand même
quatre personnes qui s'est senti
concerné par cette compétition oui oui
mais voilà après je pense pas que ce
soit non plus des supérettes en jeu si
c'est le cas on sait que la deuxième
édition ils vont venir à 400000 euros
le retour de raul
moi je pense qu'elle avait déjà un petit
enjeu orgue et organisationnelles parce
que ça permettait un petit peu d'avoir
un avant-goût de la dope surtout au
niveau des terrains de l'engouement que
la ryder cup allait créer donc pour ça
c'était assez intéressant qu'elle ait
lieu
ensuite il ya une telle demande et il ya
une telle
il ya tellement de gens qui pratiquent
le golf cet âge là et finalement on est
sur la majorité de la population donc à
ce moment là c'est la compétition prend
toute son ampleur
je pense que ça sera dans un autre sport
ça aurait pas d'enjeu mais ce qui
concerne le golfe pour moi je lui
accorde même moi je vais je vais encore
faire le parallèle avec les avec les
compétitions de cyclisme master et qui
prennent justement de plus en plus
d'ampleur avec de plus en plus de
participants aussi bien au niveau
régional national qu'à l'international
il
mais met donc je trouve que c'est très
important justement de que des sports
parce que le golf est un sport
petit peut se jouer jusqu'à très tard
petit peu ce jusque retard et donc
permettre aux gens de conserver une
une bonne santé tout simplement d'aller
se taper un 18 trous tous les week-ends
et puis peut-être d'aller d'aller jouer
d'aller jouer en plus la semaine pour
pour parfaire son swing et bien c'est
vrai que ça permet d'avoir une des
sorties régulières d'avoir une
de rencontrer des gens et donc de
continuer de vivre même c'est alors 50
ans on n'est pas à la retraite mais on
en est on s'en rapproche et donc qui dit
plus de 50 ans dit qu'il y avait des
participants qui devaient être à la
retraite et donc bien il faut s'occuper
et c'est vrai que ben passer par le
sport pour le faire c'est quelque chose
qui je pense est important et donc il
faut encourager ces initiatives
maintenant à leur décharge ils ont quand
même pas eu de bol avec la météo
donc forcément n'a pas le temps
médiatique d'antoine et éthique mais sur
l'impact du lait pour les spectateurs
est adressé et bien sûr en tout cas
fallait qu anderson ça a permis
également au golf national de se jauger
on va dire à un an pile poil de la ryder
cup 2018 qui se jouera du 28 septembre
au 30 septembre 2018 voilà ce que est ce
que ça permet est-ce que ça permet
justement de au public aux spectateurs
ou à l'organisation de se juger il ya
plusieurs aspects sur ce type de
compétition déjà pour la structure c'est
important de l'occuper c'est le plus
grand défi de tout ce qu'est stade et
tout ce qui est infrastructure c'est
qu'il faut qu'il y ait des événements
faut qu'il y ait des gens qui les
utilisent parce que sinon la structure
perd sa raison d'être de ce point de vue
là je pense que l'événement était
important en plus comme on l'a dit ça
permettait de faire une petite
répétition pour la ryder cup se voit au
niveau du parcours également servir de
ce mélange à la caisse qu'on peut
améliorer
qu'est ce qui reste encore à faire pour
préparer un événement de plus grande
ampleur après pour les pratiquants aussi
c'est important parce que c'est des
événements que eux peuvent pratiquer
donc pour le développement de l'activité
pour augmenter le nombre de licenciés
etc
pour eux aussi c'est important de pas de
tenir ce genre d'événement après du
point de vue performances et sport de
haut niveau c'est tout de suite moins
important parce que forcément on a déjà
limité on a limité les catégories d'âge
des participants généralement les
meilleurs particulière forcément la même
pression également oui et puis je pense
que c'est un peu comme au tennis je
pense que même sans même s'en faire du
jeunisme etc
c'est par exemple pour le le tennis il
ya beaucoup moins de gens qui
s'intéressent au tournoi de
des jeunes qu'à roland garros où calais
ou cas des master's comme monaco etc
donc je pense que ça dépend comment on
le regarde si on regarde un point de vue
purement médiatique etc
abbas a pas été forcément très
médiatique et pourtant on a vu qu'elle a
quand même beaucoup de beaucoup de
spectateurs pour un événement cas de
1500 personnes c'est quand même c'est
quand même un bon nombre
après après si on regarde ça y est vous
les performances pures sais pas c'est
pas l'idéal mais après le point de vue
développement du golf c'est important et
je pense que c'est à refaire les séries
continue alors le tournoi a tout de même
le mérite d'avoir diverti les fans de
john delli double vainqueur de grand
chelem il n'a pas hésité à pousser la
chansonnette pendant la compétition
on les gouttes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
genre une petite réaction par rapport à
ce mini concert
paris dow jones fait mieux vous il est
bien à huy non mais sincèrement oui non
on fera conditionné sahraouis la même
coiffure que trump
si l'on sache bien s'il faut que
j'attaque bien oui c'est monsieur mousse
qui fait l'attraction également vous
avez apprécié à l'extrait oui j'aime
bien j'aime bien ce genre de ce genre de
musique est fait et en effet et du coup
ça permet de se rendre compte qu'on est
sur le même type d'esprit que un tournoi
des légendes à roland garros avec des
des gels henri leconte ou qui sont là
pour faire le show et prendre du plaisir
et s'amuser avec le public donc c'est
pas la java c'est pourtant votre blague
jean oui effectivement john delli est
très ami avec donald trump est pas
brochure vous avez vu juste
on va passer maintenant être notre
dernière rubrique la rubrique découverte
dans cette dernière partie nous allons
nous intéresser au quidditch un sport
tout droit tiré de la saga harry potter
créé par jk rowling le concept chaque
équipe possède sept joueurs chevauchant
des balais volants
l'objectif est de marquer le plus de
points que son adversaire en marquant
des buts suspendu et en attrapant balle
magique comme vous pouvez le voir sur
ces images appelé le vif d'or un but
égale 10 points le vif d'or permis de
remporter le match
vous connaissez ce sport pas du tout je
suis pas du tout fan d'harry potter 7 ou
harry potter et puis c'est peut-être
plus de votre génération harry potter
pas fan non plus mais je me suis
intéressé quand j'étais enfant mais
après vous connaissez ce sport voilà
donc si l'auto graphique
oui les gens là on a bien là des images
je me suis dit maj du film d'art images
du film justement on n'a pas les images
parce que attendait azhari des images du
vrai voilà donc si vous voulez assister
à cette discipline un solide ce sport
fictif est devenu réalité vous pouvez
même les tester dans les yvelines
une section de quidditch baptisé les
aigles laisse hunt vient de voir le jour
aux clayes-sous-bois une première dans
le département pour attirer un maximum
de joueurs un entraînement était ouvert
aux petits et aux grands ce samedi 30
septembre au parc jean carillon on
écoute le président du club gilles
guillou en fait on n'est pas du sorcier
c'est en fait il vous dit je me le dis
parce qu'on n'a pas le on est pas on
n'est pas magicien donc on veut le pape
dont concours avec des balais mais le
but c'est gonesse est de permettre aux
enfants qui connaissent l'univers
d'harry potter ou même les grands comme
moi qu'ils puissent s'amuser courir et
puis pouvoir participer à des
compétitions
alors comme vous pouvez le voir sur ces
images n'ont pas de ballet mais ces
mêmes principes le genre la question sur
ce thème
on valide ce sport ou pas oui ou non ils
ont déballé mais qui ne veulent pas
alors non frédéric vous vous rendez vous
ont fait un petit duel entre jean et
vous frédéric fallait calaisis le
contraire de tout le monde moi je pense
qu importe c'est très bien fait avec les
courageux est ce que c'est un sport que
c'est pas un sport je pense clause qui
est important c'est que les gens ils
s'amusent et puis sont dans leur petit
monde et c'est vrai que de l'extérieur
on a vite fait de se moquer d'eux c'est
facile mais je pense que s'ils s'amusent
et que que chacun prend plaisir je pense
que c'est ça la base du sport pour le
plus grand pour la plus grande partie
plus grande partie des du public
concerné offre performance on veut dire
les balais sont censés voler c'est un
truc l'imaginaire dire non pour leur
mettre des bas des chevaux en bois ça
serait pas elle veut dire c'est pas
c'est pas sérieux
genre si on part du principe que faire
un effort physique c'est faire du sport
effectivement ils font du sport il se
dépense
bon après quand même
faut rester et on dire on ne se moque
pas d'eux déjà ne se moque pas d'eux ils
ont besoin de personne en la vie pour ça
il se rend il faisait de personnes
non honnêtement bon voilà c'est que le
jeu qu'on aime face avant vient mourir
dans l'oreillette qui cherchait un coach
justement animé la session du samedi
matin quand c'est dangereux parce que le
mal chabal est comme ça
en contact avec l'adversaire jambes
attention non mes amis si c'est quand
même oui mais c'est bien mais notamment
après les sabres laser le yiddish lama
chef de la section voit le cleach
cheechoo a bientôt la section goldorak
donc à créer
un nouveau sport une nouvelle activité
qu'il le fasse vraiment 100% avec des
pays qui veulent aider la parenté avec
des maillots de foot convient d'en voir
dans ce cas là un un vrai pseudo bas les
gens là quelque chose qui ils le font
parce que les aime l'univers d'harry
potter visé dans certaines univers de
temps voilà qu'il ne choisit pas compte
de ce qui m'inquiète un petit peu je
vais essayer mais à 1 courir avec un
mâle chabal est en train entre les
cuisses sera pas très évident et sur
l'eau comme le rappelle et robinho le
gte m non mais mais les alliés pour les
faillites allait courir
la faute à canton et va courir et qu'ils
n'ont plus entre les gens je pense que
là déjà six jeunes non plus voilà c'est
bon voilà ils sont pas là il y en a
reparlé du poste de gardien de tout à
l'heure il ya un gardien également un
gardien est fort et la mer était calme
en écho avec le ballet il arrête avec
les marques de chabal et non non c'est
vrai que je vais gérer essayer de
couvrir les cas match aller j'avais pris
l'engagement devant les téléspectateurs
de l'été mais 78 et des jeux le film eux
mêmes il y aura les vidéos vous avez
filmé la laisser voler votre crise la
prochaine fois et je vous donnerai des
tas de jan balik du reste il ya le
supporter est vraiment tous les sports
est ce que vous supportez ce sport
j'aime moi c'est très cardio apparemment
oui oui d'accord je suis j'aime le sport
là j'ai du mal pourtant il se dépense
ouais mais les passagers du match enfin
autant en face à médéric j'ai quand même
vu des matchs de quidditch sur sur le
film harry potter où il ya vraiment de
l'action là je pense que c'est quand
même très très limité et sabre laser
encore à la limite de l'action les
scream un peu comme ces voix là là là
c'est vrai que ça ressemble quand même
pas à grand chose et ça ressemble à du
rugby
ben ouais à vous de juger ça je pense
que tu me titille mais bon d'accord je
suis pas et je suis là j'ai beaucoup de
mal mais j'avoue que maintenant si on
m'invite si on invite elle et je ferai
l'effort de déplacer pour vous allez
parler les gens courent va avec un balai
entre les jambes et non pas la fin de
cette émission se retrouvent le jeudi 19
octobre pour un nouveau à 6 ans par les
sports comme pour chaque émission on va
terminer par une citation aujourd'hui
c'est le navigateur eric tabarly qui est
à l'honneur je cite baisser les bras
dans une compétition sous prétexte qu'on
ne peut pas terminer premier est
incompatible avec l'esprit du sport je
vous laisse
à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]